oh baby baby do we have a show for you
guys today brian rose was just
arrested according to him for
campaigning is it true
is by rose being persecuted or is he
just a jackass
let's find out guys the biggest cloud i
mean look i may be the owner of the
circus at this point you know covering
all these guys
but if i am brian rose is my lead show
he's my lead
uh act because nobody's clowning harder
than brian rose you remember he was mr
freedom platform
it's hard to believe that was so long
ago right now if you go to
freedomplatform.tv
donate it redirects you literally i'm
not even joking redirects you to his
campaign he's not even bothering
pretending like he cares about freedom
of speech anymore
now he's just going up onto my next
thing now mr
mayer whatever he's in last place
according to the polls
okay a quick look at the poll shows that
brian rose is gray
with other he literally doesn't even
have his own bucket
he's uh he's just bucketed in with all
the other you know millions of
irrelevant
candidates for london mayor of london
and yeah so that that's where he's at
but he keeps he he's grifting on this
and now he's making a big show of this
right i was arrested
but first of all i'm not even sure
that's true look you go to the daily
mail article about this
geez of course i have tai lopez ads
getting targeted see it's not just
you guys that get targeted with these
ridiculous ads i get targeted too
you see london mayor candidate brian
rose is fine 200 pounds so
i don't think he was arrested i think he
was fined first of all i think he's just
complaining
but second of all i want to pick apart
this little pity party
he's throwing for himself and show you
guys the truth because as soon as he
does this he sees
an opportunity right he he's trying to
get publicity because he can't get any
publicity i think this is the first time
anyone's talked about it besides me
daily mail picked up the story right
he sees it as a way to get publicity but
i want to set the record straight
because brian rose is harassing these
poor police officers for doing their job
and turning it into something it's not
brian rose if you guys don't know thinks
he's above
covered lockdown rule he thinks he he
thinks covets a hoax honestly that's
what david ike thinks and i think
he thinks the same thing because he
keeps saying oh we have a
disproportional response
to the virus but then he says we should
open up back
restaurants okay bars okay that's fine
with me
then wear a mask why are you the only
one
in this picture not wearing a mask
brian rose never wears a mask in fact he
was running around
london shaking everyone's hand doing all
this stuff
and finally these poor people stopped
him this poor officer
and then he harasses this poor lady and
tries to say it's political look at this
look at this this is the lady shutting
him down what you're doing on the
campaign
what you're doing on the campaign does
not follow the essence of the lockdown
brian turns it into this seems a little
political no
bro you're running around shaking
people's hands look at this
look at this guys look at this this is
him while he's running for mayor
he's running around no mask shaking
people's hands
and completely ignoring all guidelines
he doesn't give up
dude he doesn't care he doesn't care
look at him look at him oh
i'll shake your hand he goes yeah i'm
doing i'm covered secure it's political
that you guys are finding me
for breaking coveted rules when i'm the
only one going out
masculist shaking people's hands there
is no contact with any citizens
we are literally out there capturing
digital assets communicating with you
digitally
then he gets all conspiratorial and says
obviously you've been watching us
following us targeting us it goes on and
he says
lib dems have also been campaigning yeah
uh actually
there's some truth that but what he
doesn't tell you it's they were
leaf-litting
which means they were sticking like mail
into letterboxes
right that's they were just giving
people that that is a far cry
from this every borough in london has
its unique
challenges and your next mayor must be
on the ground
a little bit different from literally
going around shaking over his hands
like covet doesn't exist listen i'm not
i'm just gonna say this right now
if brian rose doesn't believe in cover
just say so baby
at least we know where you stand instead
you have to pretend that you didn't talk
to david ike that you don't believe in
any
you believe in cove and all this stuff
and then you do the opposite of anything
to do with covet we know where you stand
and this is just another great example
dude this is like
this stuff you can't make this stuff up
again brian's trying to play persecution
oh you persecuting me guys
i'm just following the rules like
everyone else this is brian no mask as
you can see
every other person and this is indoors
every other
person massed up and this jackass thinks
he's above the law
guys you're not above the law this is
what i hate dude
all these influencers in la all these
celebrities
like joe rogan all these guys they all
think nothing applies to them they think
oh i can go with
that a mask i don't need a mask and then
they're the exact ones that complain
about the country being locked down
you idiots are the reason the country's
still locked down
listen i agree with a lot of what these
people say about you know hey
we can't close the country down forever
i agree look i'm in texas baby
we have a lot open but the only way
things can continue to be open the only
way
you have to manage that balance right
that tipping point balance of
controlling the virus
while at the same time putting people
back to work as they should be
you have to follow protocol so when i
see people like this
this idiot grifting your money to pay
for a battle bus by the way we didn't
even talk about that because this
arrest took took over the whole story
but uh when i see this guy
saying oh my gosh i'm persecuted look at
what everyone else is doing this is
political
no you're the only one going out without
a mask there's nothing political this
poor
lady is right and she's getting harassed
by brian rose
oh you're making it political you've
been targeting us you've been following
us
doing it in a much more dangerous way
dude no they're not show me another
political campaign
that's doing this what are you talking
about dude
you're such an idiot brian and i see
right through you and i'm gonna call you
out
listen other politicians they're not
great don't get me wrong but this guy is
an opportunist
uh he doesn't care about anyone but
himself and he's an ego maniac look who
puts
who puts their face a 10-foot tall
version of their face on the side of a
bus
it takes a special type of person to do
that i mean that's even not hardly a
politician thing that's only a brian
rose thing
so um i'm stopping the campaign right
now i've been told that we cannot
[Music]
just put it put it in context he just
spent all your all the followers money
on this stupid
battle bus that he thought he was going
to run around london shaking everyone's
hands without a mask
and then he's all butt hurt about it
that he was he was fined 200 pounds he
says he was arrested he was fight 200
pounds campaigns are out there right now
campaigning as we speak on the ground
but again the only thing i'm aware of
look it might it might be different but
the only thing i'm aware of
is other campaigns are literally doing
leaflets
see the lib dem leader said his party
was acting within the law
pushing leaflets through letterboxes
that's a far cry
from this guy being the only guy without
a mask on the campaign trail
spreading cove into everybody jeez brian
rose is now appealing the penalties and
this decision to
in order to ensure that a free and fair
election takes place on london may 6th
does anybody else find that brian rose
is just like a worse version of trump
like he's like the uk
he's like copying it in every way he's
like going make london
great again whatever he like refuses to
wear a mask but he has none of the uh
the i feel like blue collar appeal
that trump had i mean i know it's weird
that trump had any blue collar appeal
because he you know he's a rich guy but
but he did he connected with that like
base
in a way that i just don't see brian
rose doing and
yet he's trying all the same like tricks
but he doesn't actually have any of the
numbers look at this guy
he can't he's not even in last place
he's
sharing last place with like eight other
people
he's going everyone's persecuting me
whatever bro you're irrelevant to the
race
you're not even in the race right now so
so yeah that's it that's the trending
news of the day brian rose was just
arrested let me know what you guys think
this is not a case of oh they knew i was
a big threat brian rose was my name on a
battle bus
and that's why they went out to get me
no this poor cop lady she saw you
just shaking people's hands going into
stores without a mask on
and she probably was like yeah you can't
do that it's like one of the worst
seasons of covert right now anyway
i know people don't want to hear that i
know they want to like go back you know
go back to work and like
open the restaurants over the marsh i do
too which is
all the more reason why you have to put
your stupid mask
on anyway i don't know i'm gonna get
heated about this
um and i know people have different
opinions on it but at least you have to
admit
that if you're the guy who says follow
the science mr brian follow the science
rose
try following the science for a change
all right that's it
thanks for watching i'll see you
[Music]
tomorrow
you